Hi,
welcome to this week's video.
Today we're going to be talking about
effect and effect and when to use each one
no to both words are pronounced pretty
similarly and therefore the distinguished
them. I'm going to pronounce
them a effect and effect.
When I was in the eighth grade,
I had an English teacher
named Mrs Christianson who
would try to get us to learn
from our mistakes by making us do a
project that would demonstrate that we had
learned the correct principle for whatever
grammar rule we had viciously though
around and very much figuratively
slaughtered and apparently died,
totally misused,
a effect and effect of the paper.
So then I went home and I
asked for my dad's helping,
thinking of some idea to put on a poster
and he greatly influenced my idea of
drawing some pictures of some rainy
scenes and then riding in my crappy eighth
grade handwriting.
The rain in Spain affects the plane and
the effect of the rain is a soggy plane,
probably because he had just
watched my fair lady. Honestly,
I still didn't fully understand the
difference between a fact and effect,
but I submitted the poster and I moved
on with my life. So without further ado,
any effect is a verb and it means to
have an influence on it can also be
technically used as a noun,
but most of the time you're
going to see it as a verb.
So in the example given earlier
the subject, in this case,
the rain doesn't action to the
direct object. In this case,
the plane,
that action is offense,
the rain affects or has an
influence on the plane effect.
On the other hand is usually announced
in effect is basically something that was
brought at bat or a result
in the example given earlier.
Effect is a noun and the subject of the
sentence and the rest of the sentence
simply describes what the effect
of the rain was on the plane.
Essentially, it caused it to
be soggy. In this example,
the dog's heartfelt
ballad affected me deeply.
We use a effect because we needed a verb
that meant to have an influence on the
dog's ballad influenced me in some way.
It affected me,
but in this example, the effect of the
dog's ballad on the cat was a brutal one.
We use effect because we needed
announced that meant result.
We could've just as easily said,
the result of the dog's ballad
on the cat was a brutal one. Yes,
effect can be used as a bird,
though it's far less common.
When he effect is used as a verb.
It means to bring about something you
will often hear effect as a verb in the
phrase effect, a change, which
means to bring about a change.
As in the phrase we need to effect
a change in the world. Basically,
if you just remember that a defect
is a verb and effect is a noun,
you'll be right most of the time.
Until next time, go watch my fair lady.
It's a classic.